Jean-Marie van llorenberg pour le groupe
de l'Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président
monsieur les ministres madame la
Présidente de la Commission mesdames
Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues veut-on d'un doux mensonge ou
d'une amère vérité
celle-ci malheureusement est claire le
système des retraites par répartition
est menacé
faut-il donc le réformer la réponse de
notre groupe
celle qui a rappelé le président
Marseille tout à l'heure
éclaire et sans ambiguïté c'est oui d'un
système conçu
à l'origine avec quatre cotisants pour
un retraité ce ratio tombent aujourd'hui
à 1,7 cotisants pour un retraité c'est
un déséquilibre évident incontestable et
qui s'accroît avec l'espérance de vie
d'aucun pensent que les hommes mentent
les chiffres un peu moins le corps
conseille d'orientation des retraites
c'est soudainement retrouvé sous les
feux de la rampe des rapports en général
indigestes sont devenus malgré eux
livrent d'éveil pour pas dire de chevet
pour certains irresponsables politiques
car il s'agit bien d'irresponsabilités à
ne retenir du corps que le seul fait que
des dépenses soient sous contrôle
c'est négliger le sujet de la dette la
dette retraite est déjà très élevée 43
milliards portés par la Cadès c'est
négliger aussi que des déficits cumulés
selon le corps d'ailleurs
représenteront 150 milliards de dettes
nouvelles en 2030 alors fallait-il
réformer dès maintenant nous répondons
encore 800 hésiter en matière climatique
on parle volontiers d'urgence de ce que
nous laisserons à nos enfants et petits
enfants il en est de même pour les
retraites et notamment pour les jeunes
qui croient de moins en moins qu'ils en
auront une
le Sénat dans sa sagesse d'ailleurs n'a
pas attendu l'agend d'un gouvernementale
pour réformer il adopte depuis plusieurs
années le recul progressif de l'âge de
départ à 64 ans avec l'accélération de
la loi Touraine bien plus juste car
recul brutale à 65 ans
la réforme proposée est-elle adaptée
notre réponse est encore affirmative si
l'on accepte comme postulat de ne pas
augmenter les cotisations retraite afin
de ne pas appeler
affaiblir pardon le pouvoir d'achat des
salariés pour lequel évidemment nous
sommes d'accord
mais en ce qui concerne la création
d'emplois j'en doute en effet admis
point de plus de cotisations employeur
représente 4 milliards et demi de
recettes en moyenne 225 euros par
salarié par an
c'est pour une entreprise de 100
salariés un peu moins qu'un poste de
travail
donc cette réforme est-elle
satisfaisante d'un point de vue
comptable oui d'un point de vue social
et politique on peut en débattre et
c'est bien cela d'ailleurs auquel nous
sommes conviés d'un point de vue social
les 17 milliards dégagés en 2030
permettront de financer 6 milliards de
mesure de solidarité et d'un point de
vue politique l'évidence c'est que les
Français n'admettent pas le recul de
l'âge à 64 ans considérant à juste titre
que seuls les salariés sont mis à
contribution une autre solution serait
évidemment d'augmenter la taxation du
capital est-ce que c'est envisageable et
bien c'est une question que je pose au
gouvernement et à ceux qui seraient
tentés de prendre tout le plat dans leur
assiette pour citer la des pierres
au nom de la solidarité nationale il ne
me paraît ni outrageant ni indécent que
les bénéficiaires d'un CAC 40 au plus
haut actuellement accepte une
augmentation de la CSG sur le capital
un point supplémentaire rapporterait un
milliard 5 alors abordons maintenant
quelques articles rapidement
saluons tout d'abord les propositions du
gouvernement pour tenter d'améliorer la
justice et l'équité du système
nous avons quelques questions parce que
certaines mesures pour certaines mesures
le diable on le sait se cache dans les
détails pour les petites retraites tout
le monde a retenu qu'il n'y aurait pas
de retraite à moins de 1200 euros mais
peu on comprit que cela concernait que
les carrières complètes alors une
suggestion celle de Lucas qui me paraît
intelligente et intelligible pourquoi ne
pas mettre un plancher à 75% du SMIC
soit 1000 euros pour les carrières
incomplètes
pour les carrières longues
le dispositif paraît serpenté de façon
erratique entre 43 et 44 ans de durée de
cotisation en fonction de l'entrée dans
la vie active il nous apparaît
nécessaire de lisser l'ensemble avec
donc des départs de 57 à 62 ans de quoi
ouvrir une fenêtre d'ailleurs de départ
de 57 à 64 ans chers aux économistes
Blanchard et Tyrol et beaucoup plus
jeune plus juste qu'une borne unique de
départ à 64 ans
pour les seniors le gouvernement décide
de s'intéresser aux fins de carrière
mais je crains que l'index Seigneur
proposait une Swagger suffisant pour
répondre à l'intention qu'il manifeste
il nous semble que c'est index doit être
accompagné d'une prime à l'embauche
sorte de un seigneur une solution et que
pourquoi pas d'ailleurs un CDI senior et
nous ne devrions pas faire l'économie
d'un bonus malus sur la base de cette
index pour favoriser le maintien des
seigneurs dans l'emploi
pour les droits familiaux
nous proposions donc avant la hache de
l'article 40 un départ anticipé à 62 ans
pour trois enfants et 63 ans pour deux
mais nous constatons aussi de fortes
disparité dans les droits familiaux la
réversion particulière ou 13 régimes
subsistent et qu'il sera nécessaire de
revoir dans la prochaine loi enfin
la pénibilité la Pénélope du travail que
l'on s'y arrête un petit peu plus nous y
sommes attentifs bien entendu nous
sommes attentifs à la réflexion aussi
sur le travail la nécessité de lui
donner plus de sens nous sommes aussi
tous aussi vigilants face à ceux qui
contesteraient la valeur du travail il
n'appartient pourtant pas à cette loi de
financement évidemment de la sécurité
sociale de traiter de ce sujet beaucoup
trop complexe où tous les points de vue
divers chevaux suivant évidemment le
point dont de duquel on se place du
point de vue de quel on se place alors
faisons venons-en à ce qui nous
préoccupe vraiment c'est à dire réparer
l'usure professionnelle la loi dans ce
domaine est généreuse elle prend en
compte les trois autres critères
d'ergonomiques qui donneront lieu à un
suivi médical c'est bien mais il nous
paraît nécessaire de compléter ce bilan
avec un bilan de compétences pour
envisager l'avenir sérieusement enfin un
mot pour conclure sur ce qui nous tient
à coeur à nous Centris le dialogue
social nous regrettons qu'il est tourné
court que certains partenaires sociaux
et responsables politiques et refusé
d'emblée le diagnostic du corps du corps
avant d'y consenti que d'autres est crus
que la désinformation est listerie
pouvait remplacer le débat aussi ce vrai
débat que chacun mérite et qui pourra je
l'espère se nouer ici au Sénat aucune
réponse n'est faite pour l'éternité
plusieurs dates jalonnent deux décennies
de réforme des retraites s'y ajoutera
sans aucun doute 2023 et peut-être aussi
2027 avec la réforme présidentielle pour
cela nous pensons qu'il est bon qui est
une clause de revoyure ou plutôt un
bilan d'étapes produit par la Cour des
comptes afin d'assurer peut-être la
sérénité du débat qui suivra comme celui
qui je l'espère pourra se dérouler ici
demain dans cette assemblée merci
beaucoup merci
merci mon cher collègue
je vais donner dans la parole au